Deputy Prime Minister has been announced
we weren't sure whether the PM would
actually appoint a new Deputy Prime
Minister that is Oliver Dowden yes
um breaking news again the Prime
Minister has just appointed Oliver
Dowden as his Deputy Prime Minister now
Oliver Dowden again a key Ally of Rishi
uh sunak he is currently running the
cabinet office so the Machinery of
government and you might remember Oliver
Dowden because he was the party chair
yeah who back in I think it was June
after the conservatives lost two key
local elections I remember it because we
were in Rwanda for the chogum for the
people in that morning yeah for the
Commonwealth Summit and Oliver Dowden
that morning as Boris Johnson had tried
to brush off these losses sort of blew
the whole edifice open
um when he said that he was resigning
and when everyone talks about the
resignation process
um that triggered Boris Johnson's
departure everyone tends to talk about
it being Sajid Javid uh follow who was
then the house actually followed by
Rishi Suna but actually it was Oliver
Dowden he was the first cabinet
resignation